[Música]
fue uno de Los Conquistadores más
temibles que han existido y libró una
imparable conquista por todo el
continente euroasiático
pero gengis Khan fue un bárbaro
despiadado o un unificador que allanó el
camino para el mundo moderno lo veremos
en la historia versus game is Khan
orden Quién es el acusado hoy
su señoría veo que está familiarizado
con games Khan el conquistador del siglo
13 cuya campaña militar mató a millones
y no dejó nada más que una Estela de
destrucción
objeción primero que nada se pronuncia
chinguis hand de verdad sí en mongolia
además fue uno de los más grandes
líderes en la historia de la humanidad
nacido quedó huérfano indigente cuando
era niño pero superó constantes
conflictos para unificar los clanes
guerreros de mongolia
y forjó el más grande Imperio que el
mundo haya visto que finalmente se
extendió desde el Pacífico hasta Europa
central Qué hay de grandioso en la
invasión y la matanza el norte de China
perdió dos tercios de su población
la dinastía jin fue hostigada por las
tribus del Norte les pagó para pelear
entre ellas y periódicamente las atacaba
no estaba dispuesto a sufrir el mismo
destino que el último han que trató de
unificar a los mongoles y el cambio
demográfico reflejaría un pobre
mantenimiento del censo sin mencionar
que muchos campesinos eran llevados al
ejército de Jan puede analizar todos los
números que desee Pero ellos aniquilaron
ciudades enteras y a todos sus
habitantes el han prefería enemigos que
se rindieran y pagaran tributos y creía
firmemente en la lealtad y la ley
diplomática las ciudades masacradas eran
las que se revelaban después de Rendirse
designadas como Embajadores lo suyo fue
un entendimiento estricto de la justicia
muchos relatos cuentan que la brutalidad
de su ejército excedía la justicia
arrancaban bebés del vientre de sus
madres usaban prisioneros como escudos
humanos o como relleno de fosos para
sostener armas de asedio tomaban a todas
las mujeres de los pueblos conquistados
suficiente Qué es salvaje realmente es
mucho peor que otros ejércitos
medievales no Es excusa para las
atrocidades de gengis Khan pero hace de
algo excepcional para su tiempo de hecho
después de su unificación con las tribus
abolió el rapto de novias a las mujeres
mongolas les iba mejor que a la mayoría
controlaban los asuntos domésticos
podían divorciarse de sus esposos y eran
consejeras de confianza que muy bien
permaneció con su primera esposa toda su
vida incluso creó como propio a su
posible Hijo ilegítimo de todas formas
el legado fue un desastre 40 millones de
muertos en eurasia durante las
conquistas de sus descendientes el 10%
de la población mundial sin incluir las
muertes por la peste negra llevadas a
Europa por la horda de oro después del
asedio acafa no debe haber sido
intencional en realidad cuando vieron
morir a sus tropas por la peste
catapultaron los cuerpos infectados
encima de las murallas de la ciudad
los relatos a los que se refiere fueron
escritos más de Cien años después de los
Hechos qué tan confiables cree que son
los sobrevivientes cosecharon los frutos
del imperio que fundó
frutos el Imperio mongol practicó la
tolerancia religiosa entre todas las
personas trataban bien a sus soldados
eran ascendidos por méritos no por
linaje establecieron un amplio sistema
postal y fortalecieron el estado de
derecho sin mencionar su contribución a
la cultura
te refieres a la forma en que hulaku
kang exterminó Bagdad la capital
cultural de la época bibliotecas
hospitales y Palacios quemados canales
de riego enterrados
fue desafortunada porque el califa se
negó a Rendirse y luego
castigó a Julia por la destrucción
desmedida no era política de mongolia
destruir la cultura usualmente salvaban
a médicos sabios y artesanos de los
lugares conquistados y los llevaban por
el reino para que difundieran sus
conocimientos por el mundo
qué me dice de la devastación de kieván
Rose que dejó a su gente en la Edad
Oscura incluso cuando el renacimiento
proliferaba en el oeste de Europa el
oeste de Europa no era Pacífico en esos
tiempos la estabilidad de la ley mongol
la hizo florecer la ruta de la seda una
vez más y permitió el comercio y el
intercambio cultural entre el este y el
oeste su legado llevó a Rusia y China de
principados violentos a Estados
unificados de hecho mucho Después del
imperio se pueden hallar descendientes
de
La Nobleza De toda eurasia no
sorprendería que un tirano Inspire a más
Tiranos cuidado con como lo llama podría
ser familiar qué actualmente hay 16
millones de personas descendientes de
eso es uno de cada 200 por cada gran
conquistador hay millones de
conquistados cuál de estas historias
sobrevivirá podrá el significado
histórico o cultural de un líder pesar
más que las muertes que provocó en su
camino Estas son las preguntas que
surgen cuando llevamos a la historia a
juicio
siga poniendo en tela de juicio a
figuras controversiales con este video
sobre Vladimir Lenin fue un héroe o un
Villano es usted quien decide o continúe
explorando el legado de genki scan y el
Imperio mongol que se convirtió en uno
de los imperios más grandes de la
historia con este video